(pulsing electronic tones)
- [Narrator] More governments
are kicking people
off the internet than ever before.
It usually happens during
politically-sensitive times
like elections, protests, and conflicts.
Last year, governments
shut down the internet
more frequently than in previous years
according to a digital rights group
that started tracking
the practice in 2011.
For instance, in India,
it happened in parts of the
country more than 100 times.
Authorities say shutdowns help stop unrest
and the spread of fake news
and even prevent cheating on school exams.
Advocates for an open
internet say shutdowns
can cripple economies
and disrupt daily life
all while curtailing civil rights,
so here's how governments can
kick you off the internet.
Usually when you type in
a URL or hit an app icon,
the Domain Name System
looks up that address
and resolves it to a string
of pre-assigned numbers.
In under a second, you can
usually connect to the server
and access the site.
If the government wants to
block access to a specific site,
it can request the
Internet service provider
to interfere with the DNS traffic.
The provider can then redirect traffic
so it never reaches those servers.
This happened last year at the
height of a political crisis
in Venezuela when opposition
leader Juan Guaido
tried to seize power from
President Nicolas Maduro.
Guaido was standing with soldiers
outside a military base
when he began live-streaming on Twitter.
(Juan speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] He called people to rise up
against President Nicolas Maduro.
While Guaido's call to action
ricocheted across the world,
at home, his message was blocked
for a large number of internet users.
This chart shows that Venezuela's
state-run internet provider
restricted access to social media.
The company didn't respond
to a request for comment.
- We're looking at something
similar to radio censorship
or TV censorship when
authorities might bleep out
parts of a sentence or a speech.
- [Narrator] Alp Toker is the founder
of an internet advocacy
group called NetBlocks.
He says it's surprisingly
easy for the government
to turn off access to specific sites.
- [Alp] This is basically an engineer
with a button on the switch.
When they see something they don't like,
they press the button.
- [Narrator] But authorities
can be more subtle
in how they control the internet,
not just by blocking sites,
but by simply slowing down the connection.
(bubble popping)
(pleasant electronic music)
This is called throttling,
so it looks like you're
apps are still running
when, in fact, the
interference is at a level
that makes using the internet painful,
so the video you're
trying to watch on YouTube
becomes very low res or it keeps loading.
We spoke to network engineers
who monitor internet censorship,
and they say that it's even hard for them
to really pinpoint the specific reason
behind a slow connection,
and they say that's likely
why some governments
have turned to throttling
to shrug off accountability.
In some extreme cases,
governments can order service providers
to turn off the internet completely.
This happened last year during
anti-government protests
in Iraq when the internet was cut off.
(phone buzzing)
- You connect the WiFi
and opened the browser,
there is nothing and the
provider sent us messages
we are sorry because the
government cut off the internet.
- [Narrator] Ameer Hazim
is an Iraqi photographer
in Baghdad, and he's been
posting his photos on Instagram.
The Iraqi Prime Minister at the time said
it's the government's
right to restrict access
when the internet is being
used to stoke violence
and conspiracy against the homeland.
Because internet blackouts
disrupt critical services
and can hurt the economy,
authorities often target specific networks
and geographic areas.
At the height of the protests in Iraq,
the government imposed
daily digital curfews
between five p.m. to seven a.m.
Then during business hours,
the government ordered service providers
to turn on the connection again.
We spoke to private companies
in several countries,
and they say they have little
power to refuse a request
because authorities can threaten
to terminate their licenses.
Citizens have looked for workarounds
like using VPNs that connect to networks
outside of the country.
Some will pay for expensive
satellite connections.
Others, like Hazim, have
bought international SIM cards
from Jordan that are activated
before entering Iraq.
- That helped us to keep people updated.
I started during lives from Tahrir Square
showing the area around
and what's happening really
and how people are living
and how the government are using violence.
- [Narrator] Toker says these solutions
may end up encouraging
more aggressive moves from the government.
- The more people
attempt to get around it,
the more governments are
gonna try to switch it off.
- [Narrator] The UN says
restrictions on internet access
are a violation of human rights,
but many countries already have laws
that make it legal to
shut down the internet
on grounds related to national security
or stopping the spread of fake news.
- [Alp] So while this
might have started off
as authoritarian dictatorship move,
it gets encoded into laws.
It becomes very difficult
for the public to complain about it.
(buzzing electronic tones)